[Music]
as i'm speaking right now
we are already approaching 170 million
kobe cases worldwide
and more than 3 million deaths the
numbers are continuing to rise
every single day you might have lost a
loved one or perhaps
you know someone who has we're at that
one and a half years mark of living with
a kovit 19 pandemic
and it has been extremely tough for
everybody the fact is
this pandemic won't be going away
anytime soon as we have been hoping for
some of you might have already
contracted it and has recovered or
is still recovering from it if you
haven't contracted it
i hope you will still find this video
useful to share it with your family and
friends
the symptoms and recovery process is
different for everybody
some might only experience mild symptoms
whereas for some
it's more severe this video is meant to
offer you a basic
guideline on how you can get back into
exercising
after covid for those who have had mild
to moderate symptoms remember if you're
in doubt you should always refer to a
healthcare professional for advice
it is very normal to feel tired weak or
short of breath when you are recovering
from kovit19
this may last for six to eight weeks or
even longer for some
but that doesn't mean you should remain
inactive
being active can help you to recover
quicker
for athletes or those who use to have a
very active lifestyle
it is important to remind yourself to
start slow
and avoid competing with your pre-cove
itself
yes you will see a drop in your
endurance and strength
i understand that it can be very
frustrating but this is a virus that
affects
major parts of the body even if you had
only mild symptoms you should still wait
until you have
at least seven days with no symptoms
before returning to exercise so let's
look at a simple
four-step approach to help you get back
into exercising
and what you should do on a week-to-week
basis
the first phase of week one is to start
with very light intensity activities
start at just 50 of your normal
intensity
start with light walks stationary biking
yoga
pilates or low intensity body weight
strength and conditioning training
keep the duration of your exercise under
15 minutes
here are some exercises on my youtube
channel which you can follow
all the links will be in my description
box below
so this phase is to ease you slowly back
into exercising without putting
too much strain on your body if you do
experience
chest pain headache dizziness shortness
of breath or
rapid breathing then you need to ease
back and take it down a notch by
reducing
your workout time or reduce the
intensity
even more
as you move into phase 2 or week 2
you can start to increase the workout
duration to 15
to 30 minutes you can still continue
with the activities from phase 1
but increase the workout duration and
intensity slightly more
so at this phase you should be able to
hold a full conversation without
difficulty
when performing light intensity
exercises so here are some exercises on
my youtube channel which you can follow
as well
again i've created a playlist and all
the links
will be in my description box below
[Music]
now that you have been active for 2
weeks and slowly regained your stamina
in phase 3 or week 3 you can start to
increase the workout intensity to 75
percent of your pre covered fitness
this is where you can include weight
training and circuit training
so start by performing slightly more
intense exercises with a block of
recovery
and include two to three times of weight
lifting
to build your strength and muscle mass
you can also start to increase your
workout duration
from 30 to 45 minutes
once again you can follow the homework
videos on my youtube channel
right here
as we enter into the final phase which
is week
4 this should challenge your
coordination
strength and also endurance in this
phase
it can be a mixture of body weight
exercises
circuit training and weight lifting if
you are
feeling that you're back to your usual
self you can increase the workout
intensity
even more and workout duration from
45 to 60 minutes i've included
some slightly more intense workouts
which you can check it out right here on
my youtube channel
after the entire four weeks if you feel
that you have fully recovered
then you can resume back to your usual
workout routine however it is still
very important for you to monitor
yourself after
each workout session if there is
abnormal breathlessness
abnormal heart rate excessive fatigue or
chest pain
it is very important for you to stop any
activities or
ease up and seek advice from a
healthcare professional
while exercising is important for your
health and recovery journey
it is also essential to avoid pushing
yourself too far
doing so could slow down your recovery
or
cause your symptoms to worsen by
increasing the levels of
inflammation in the body so listen to
your body
take it slow and follow these four
phases
by gradually reintroducing exercise
into your routine in most countries
fitness centers are still shut
and some countries might not allow
outdoor activities to stop the spread of
kobe 19.
so i hope that my home-based workout
videos will continue to keep you active
and healthy at home and help you through
your recovery process
all the links mentioned in this video
will be in my description box below
and if you find this video to be useful
do give this video a thumbs up
share it on with your family members and
friends and let's fight together to stop
the spread of kovit 19.
do also check out other fitness videos
on my youtube channel and also a lot of
healthy recipes
and i will see you next time stay safe